trying to tries to point the finger of
blame at the u.s. some of the media and
on the left are calling out people for
labeling the virus the same way that
many of them did just weeks ago it's
starting to hear the Republicans
especially Trump Co calling it the Wuhan
or the Chinese coronavirus the Chinese
coronavirus a foreign virus foreign
virus as a quote foreign virus it's
going to come across to a lot of
Americans as smacking of xenophobia
they're looking for someone to blame
okay dr. Michael Pillsbury director of
the Center on Chinese strategy at the
Hudson Institute is here tonight to join
us always great to have you doctor
thanks Shannon
okay so right before you joined us
tonight you tweeted and linked to this
article out of China daily that talks
about the Chinese are now willing to
work with the US and other places when
it comes to vaccines out one of the I
have to read a quote from one of the
officials says it is more important now
than ever for the international
community to strengthen scientific
operations since we're very willing to
enhance our cooperation and share our
knowledge with other countries are you
surprised by that or no I was very
surprised they revealed these three
field trials that they are working on
three different kinds of vaccines with
American companies as their partners in
each case they're also working on
testing the drug that the FDA hasn't
approved yet in the US but they say
they're testing 100 250 Chinese to see
how how much it damages down the virus
this whole thing Shannon is part of what
the president Trump's been successful at
the last three years trying to balance
this Chinese nationalism the hardline
attacks on us trying to undermine us
around the world with their
disinformation campaign on the other
hand they hold out lots of really
helpful things very helpful information
you know basically hinting that they can
be our partner if we would just ease off
on the trade talks so the president has
to balance these two these two sides of
the equation yeah and there's been a lot
of talk about the supply chain issues
with China what works on them for not
only drugs but all kinds of
other things that we manufacture in
China it is cheaper there the rules are
different there in a piece on fox news
on opinion ben shapiro writes us the
solution to vulnerable supply chains
running through authoritarianism
countries to consider security threats
when formulating trade policy and second
for companies to harden their supply
chains by diversifying those chains even
further we should remember that crises
exacerbate underlying issues they rarely
create them so how do we get to this
place that we now have a global pandemic
and were dependent on China for certain
things well one thing the president has
said that the Chinese admire he said
this is not the fault of China I don't
blame the Chinese for trying to become
the number one power in the world he
says I blame previous American
presidents for letting this happen some
of the supply chain dependency goes back
more than 20 years it's worse than that
as I try to outline in hundred-year
marathon we have shared all of our
scientific discoveries a lot of our new
technology with China for free by
written agreement for more than 30 years
President Trump is trying to cut this
back and review it but this problem has
gone on for three decades now then the
big news really is the number of
Americans like Senator Marco Rubio and
others who are waking up and say my god
this is outrageous but we're way behind
there almost are equal economically they
make the scientific discoveries now that
we wonder why we are not doing that and
frankly this year they're gonna launch
almost twice as many satellites as we
will so they're they're pulling ahead in
a lot of categories and I think the
President Trump is right this has to do
with previous American presidents
tolerating it or just plain not knowing
okay so the fact that we have a business
model that seems at this point I'm told
the numbers as high as 80% we've seen in
public reports out there of our
pharmaceuticals or portions of our
pharmaceuticals that are actually
manufactured or controlled or have to
come from China will there be do you
think long-term changes because of CO
vid 19 to that how would we do that is
it possible at this point
well there's been some legislation
already introduced to try to reduce our
dependency
on it's not just on pharmaceuticals
there's quite a few areas where we have
my negligence basically letting
companies make their own decisions we've
outsourced a large part of our
manufacturing base to China we also
shared innovation ideas with them we've
signed agreements where we have to do
this unless the agreements were are
changed frankly their technology theft
also has been very focused Jenin on our
technology innovation areas they know
what they're doing this isn't just
random theft of ideas they're they're
trying to become number one and field by
field and they've gotten pretty far
already so Congress press has a huge
role to play here they do dr. Michael
Pillsbury great to have you with us sir
have a great weekend I'm trying to be
optimistic Janet yeah aren't we all
thank you sir